هكذا استقبلت مكه المكرمه اولى طلائع
الحجاج في الاهازيج الفرائحيه وكذلك
الاستقبال
والسرور الذي امتلا في هذه الاركان
لاستقبال اولى طلائع الحجاج في عام 20 23
حيث استقبلت مركز النواريه ولا طلائع
الحجاج عبر عشره حافلات صباحا وعشره
حافلات مساء سيكون العدد حتى المساء اليوم
دخلوا الى مكه استعدادا للحج ولو كان
مبكرا قبل شهر ونصف اكثر من 500 حاج قدموا
ووصلوا الى مكه المكرمه عبر السلسله من
الخدمات بدات من مطار الملك عبد العزيز في
جده في امتدادا الى هذا المركز ودخولا الى
داخل مكه المكرمه اشاهد عدد من المسؤولين
الذين يستقبلون الحجاج مسؤولين وزاره الحج
والعمره الذي نستقبلوا الحجاج بالورود
وبالهدايا
ولعمل الضيافه لهم قبل دخولهم الى مكه
المكرمه استعدادا لاداء المراسك بعد شهر
ونصف الشهر من الان
[موسيقى]
نحن بنحاول قدر المستطاع انه الفتره اللي
يقضيها الحاج من اول وصوله الى المطار حتى
وصوله الى مكان سكنه ما يكون فيها اي مجال
الانتصار فيكون كلها مسبقه التحضير يعني
الان الحبلتين الان استقبلناها قبل دقائق
كان جميع بيانات الحجاج كانت مرتضى من قبل
48 ساعه عارفين بالضبط فين ساكنين مجرد
وصف وصولهم حتى وقائمه الحجاج تاتي بشكل
مباشر طريقه الكترونيه
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الحجاج قطعوا مسافه كبيره ومن اجل
هذه المسافه ومن اجل ان لا يكون هنالك
اجهاد عليهم يعمل المسؤولون في وزاره الحج
وكذلك كافه الجهات السعوديه على تسهيل
اجراءاتهم حيث قبل ان يقلعوا من بلادهم
بنغلاديش تم تسهيل اجراءاتهم عبر مبادره
الطريق الى مكه وهنا عمليه انتظارهم لا
تستغرق وقتا طويلا حتى يدخلوا الى داخل
مكه المكرمه استعدادا للقيام بالعمره
وكذلك الحج قبل شهر كامل منه على ان
تتوالى عمليات الاستقبال خلال الايام
القادمه مع وصول اول طلائع الحجاج عبد
المحسن الحربي العربيه مكه المكرمه برامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات